[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans le sac
est loisible toutes vos idées sorties
culturelles ou ludiques dans le
département merci de nous retrouver pour
ce nouveau numéro on commence tout de
suite avec le sommaire de ce vendredi 3
novembre
il ya cent ans la première guerre
mondiale déchirait notre pays aux
clayes-sous-bois une manifestation est
dédiée à la mémoire de cet événement du
6 au 19 novembre
troisième édition pour la ville avec
cette année la thématique des femmes
dans la grande guerre spectacles
expositions et conférences
le point sur la programmation avec
neutralité il est toujours possible de
se lancer dans l'équitation au centre
équestre de ligne de loisirs de saint
quentin en yvelines il reste des places
pour découvrir l'univers du cheval ou se
perfectionner
depuis la rentrée quelques nouveautés
ont également fait leur apparition et
qui sait une fois votre monture adopté
pourquoi ne pas aller au far-west
indiens et cow boys ont envahi la
bergerie nationale de rambouillet
mélanie a dégainé ses flèches pour nous
ramener quelques informations
et plus que quelques jours pour profiter
du parc france miniature avant sa
fermeture hivernale vous avez jusqu'à
dimanche 5 novembre pour découvrir ou
redécouvrir le parc et la compagnie
focus présente à l'occasion d'halloween
donnera une dernière représentation ce
dimanche les petits monstres sont
invités à les suivre dans leurs comptes
et souvenirs parfois étranges ou
mystérieux le froid arrive à grands pas
mais ne remballer pas encore vos gants
ni vos pelles car c'est le moment de
jardiner même en novembre neil en
novembre la binette est encore bien
utile mettez de la couleur avec des
fleurs automnale planter des arbres
fruitiers comme le pommier ou utiliser
les feuilles mortes en guise d'engrais
c'est la meilleure période pour préparer
son jardin en vue des beaux jours
et oui en un sens le printemps c'est
dans moins de six mois
le point avec etienne désir paysagiste
et directeurs de jardins de la vallée au
micro de nicolas landry alors
effectivement il fait un peu plus frais
etc
mais c'est ce qu'on appelle la descente
de sève donc c'est à dire c'est là où
les végétaux vont entrer en vaut
commencer à hiberner et donc vont
remettre de la racine en pleine terre
les feuilles mortes j'allais dire que
c'est purement esthétique donc certaines
personnes
vont vouloir ratisser alors par exemple
sur le gazon effectivement les enlever
par contre on peut s'en servir comme de
terreau dans les massifs c'est à dire
les soufflés dans les massifs et après
bêcher donc les incorporés en terre
[Musique]
la première guerre mondiale 14-18 celle
qui était censée être la der des ders
pour reprendre l'expression un conflit
traumatisant qui a causé plus de 18
millions de morts à travers le monde
c'est pour ne pas les oublier que les
clayes sous bois organise depuis trois
ans un moment de commémoration à
l'occasion du centenaire du 6 au 19
novembre
plusieurs événements sont proposés à
l'espace philippe noiret avec nous par
jamin bolland directeur du développement
social et culturel de la ville bonjour
alors cette année c'est donc la
troisième édition de cette quinzaine
dédiée au devoir de mémoire de la
première guerre mondiale
comment est venue l'idée de créer cet
événement bas 2-2 dynamique associative
voilà il ya plusieurs associations qui
travaillait beaucoup sur cette question
depuis depuis un moment par la
généalogie par les recherches
historiques et puis l'idée c'était de
regrouper ces dynamiques pour en faire
un collectif voilà on a associé les
collèges l'éducation nationale les
associations la vie les services de la
ville et puis bah ensemble on a
construit chaque année voilà autour de
thématiques précises
on essaie de construire à la fois des
événements qui rappellent qu'ils sont
obligés de mémoire voilà mais aussi de
lier l'événement avec notre actualité
aujourd'hui comment cet événement a
participé à la construction du monde qui
tel qu'il est aujourd'hui
et puis de retrouver aussi des dés de
produire des créations locales soit en
récoltant du souvenir soit en
travaillant avec les plus jeunes autour
de créations spécifiques et vous l'avez
dit chaque année vous déclinez un thème
donc cette année 2010 est le thème c'est
la place des femmes dans la grande
guerre oui bah on a choisi ce thème
parce que l'année dernière c'était des
combattants étrangers et voilà aussi les
femmes ont souvent été oublié dans voilà
dont les souvenirs collectifs certains
généraux disait que si les femmes
arrêtées de travailler dans les usines
plus d'une heure la guerre aurait été
perdu voilà c'est pour montrer toute
l'importance du rôle des femmes qui ont
qui ont acquis ont comblé le manque
d'hommes maintenant tous les domaines
voilà l'infirmerie
les usines la boulangerie voilà tout ce
qui est l agriculture à toutes les
femmes sont devenues les forces vives du
pays puisque les hommes étaient partis
au front c'est elle qui tenait un peu le
prix le pays à bras à bras le corps
parfait et ça c'est souvent un hommage
qui ne l'auraient pas rendu puisque
celle ci aussi le départ des mouvements
d'émancipation
voilà féminin en france malheureusement
malgré leur participation active à la
première guerre mondiale elles n'ont pas
le droit de vote
en 1918 a fallu apprendre un deuxième
effort de guerre d'accord on va encore
attendre effectivement et cette
quinzaine hommage commence lundi 6
novembre mais la soirée de lancement
officiel elle c'est le vendredi 10
novembre à 18h30 à l'espace philippe
noiret qu'est-ce que vous avez concocté
je peux vous dire les surprises mais
principalement on n'a que les gens pour
que dès leur arrivée ils soient dans une
ambiance où on essaie de transmettre des
choses on est des plus petits aux plus
âgés donc il ya des improvisations des
jeunes de la mjc qui reprennent le thème
de la place de la femme c'est la
présentation de l'ensemble des
expositions
c
aussi on partage le discours du maire
qui nous parle aussi de l'importance
pour elle de participer à cet événement
et on remercie aussi la mission
centenaire qui nous a labellisé depuis
plusieurs années et puis on diffuse un
court métrage un peu particulier voilà
qui est qu'il ya eu pas mal de prix à
son entier des sorties voilà et puis
après on boit le verre de l'amitié on
passe au spectacle qui suit la soirée de
voile à la soirée de lancement du court
métrage alors justement ces lettres de
femmes qui sera projeté lors de cette
soirée
je vous propose de regarder un extrait
de la bande annonce et on se retrouve
juste après
un pur bien par ici
t'as du courrier laisse pas faire
mon âme chérie je n'ai plus de nouvelles
depuis plusieurs semaines et je prie le
bon dieu qui ne se soit rien arrivé ici
à la ferme nous avons bien de la misère
à venir à bout du labeur on manque de
main d'oeuvre pour les semences
j'espère que tu seras de retour moisson
sinon je ne sais pas comment on fera la
récolte l'attentât
les faire les femmes donc on l'a entendu
un qui devait s'occuper des fermes seul
de travailler à l'usiné faire tourner en
quelque sorte le pays pendant que les
hommes étaient sur le front
et c'est justement ce quotidien qui est
aussi raconté dans une pièce proposée le
10 novembre à 20h30 également les filles
aux mains jaunes alors un petit mot
rapidement sur cette pièce
alors ça ça parle des obusiers en fait
toutes ces femmes qui travaillaient dans
l'est dans les constructions d'armement
voilà qui mettaient en place les obus et
qui avait les mains jaunes parce que les
produits étaient été très dangereux et
beaucoup sont mortes dans ses usines
pour construire les obus et c'est aussi
là que sont nés les premiers mouvements
d'émancipation dont on parle et
syndicaux et aussi de mouvements de
libération de la femme
donc à ne pas manquer et surtout du 6 au
19 novembre également une exposition qui
est installée dans l'espace ce philippe
noiret dont qui décline différentes
thématiques
oui l'exposition c'est surtout sur les
aviatrices puisque le il ya c'était pour
mettre aussi à l'honneur toutes les je
vous disais on fait le lien entre
la guerre 14-18 mais le monde
d'aujourd'hui est beaucoup de
navigatrice française l'histoire des
aviatrices française aînés souvent de la
guerre 14-18 des hommes vont commencer
les as des as on les appelait voilà et
les femmes commençaient aussi en 14,8 à
voler et ensuite tu racontes tout le
siècle voilà autour de la femme et sa
passion pour l'aviation donc découvrir
en tout cas toute cette histoire merci
beaucoup benjamin ball hand est revenu
sur notre plateau donc on le rappelle le
centenaire de la guerre 14-18 aux
clayes-sous-bois c'est du 6 au 19
novembre et à ne pas manquer la soirée
de lancement du 10 le programme complet
est à retrouver sur le site internet de
la ville merci marc bolland ça vous
c'est le moment de se mettre en selle à
lille de loisirs de saint quentin en
yvelines le centre équestre propose des
séances découvertes dans le cadre dans
le cadre de l'opération équitation pour
tous six séances à 50 euros du 22
novembre au 21 janvier il est encore
temps de s'inscrire
d'autant plus que le centre a opéré
quelques changements depuis la rentrée
regarder
[Musique]
un peu farceur les nouveaux venus du
centre équestre de l'île de loisirs de
saint quentin en yvelines
julie est monitrice d'équitation depuis
deux ans son rôle former les jeunes
cavaliers pour la compétition et surtout
développer la relation avec leur monture
à ces parcours avec beaucoup de nouveaux
projets dont des bébés et des tout
jeunes lever trop juste des bourines
c'est pour ça que c'est un petit peu
branlant au départ mais il faut les
former ses cavaliers là qui les forment
des coups sur les toits et à des
complicités qui se crée des affinités
qui se créent et on essaye de
privilégier ses affinités là parce que
surtout sur le dressage de jeunes
chevaux
c'est le plus important en fait là
vraiment vraiment deux ans comme julie
six autres moniteurs et soigneurs
travaille ici depuis le 28 août la
structure est devenue ski équitation et
à changer de gestionnaire la région
ile-de-france reste propriétaire mais
c'est la société privée dahlia qui a
repris les rênes
si l'offre du centre reste la même les
modalités elle intègre lui un nouveau
site internet une nouvelle page facebook
et les adhérents ou mêmes extérieur on
possibilité maintenant de pouvoir
s'inscrire en ligne d'effectuer des
règlements en ligne de pouvoir régler
aussi en plusieurs fois
ce qui était quelque chose de beaucoup
plus complexe quand on est géré par par
l'état après 20 ans d'existence le
centre équestre compte aujourd'hui 250
adhérents débutants ou confirmés
cette nouvelle gestion devrait lui
apporter un coup de jeune avec quelques
investissements
une nouvelle carrière et une dizaine de
boxe sont prévues
[Musique]
à la bergerie nationale on vit dans le
far west depuis le début des vacances
mélanie vous avez galoper juste à
rambouillet la rencontre des cowboys et
des indiens
c'est une tradition à à rambouillet
chaque année pour les vacances de la
toussaint les cowboys et les indiens
débarque pour proposer tout un tas
d'activités alors les vacances sont
quasi terminés mais le départ pour le
far west est encore possible puisque les
animations dure jusqu'à dimanche
il faut bien sûr choisir son camp l'idée
c'est qu'on a mis en place des ateliers
créatifs où ils peuvent se déguiser
comme un cow-boy ou comme un indien
il ya aussi des petites initiation au
tir à l'arc eux tient à la carabine
il ya aussi une initiation au cheval
mécanique et le clou de l'après-midi
l'attaqué de la diligence
ouais c'est le rendez vous à ne pas
manquer c'est là où le choix du camp est
fondamentale puisque en plus il ya une
épreuve de force qui est proposé un tir
à la corde pour voir qui gagne mais bien
sûr ça se joue en équipe et les
animations ont débuté il ya bientôt deux
semaines mais les cowboys sont en
mauvaise posture actionnaires à la
bergerie ce mardi et le score était déjà
sans appel pour les indiens c'est cette
victoire à troyes pour les indiens alors
la bergerie a besoin de renfort s'il ya
des supers corus est l'occasion et c'est
aussi l'occasion d'apprendre à danser la
conterie la danse des cow boys et
surtout il ya une nouveauté cette année
un cimetière de quoi frissonner quelques
instants l'entrée est libre et les
activités se feront que les parents et
les indiens sont partout ils ont aussi
envahi versailles
ils ont carrément enlever still have à
la mairie puisque avec sans doute le
plus célèbre d'entre eux incertains il
ya karim et le petit indien a été créée
par derib il ya 48 ans l'expo se termine
elle aussi dimanche en novembre et vous
pourrez découvrir comment le dessinateur
suisse crée des chevaux la technique
pour dessiner un chouette c'est surtout
d'en avoir monté pour pouvoir les
connaître les avoir senti de savoir
comment des muscles bouge
quand on galope quand tu entres autres
cantons sont un obstacle
et comme j'ai vécu pendant 30 ans je
pense que je suis à même vous devez
décider correctement alors deux
rendez-vous pour partir de l'autre côté
de l'atlantique mais camille vous êtes
plutôt cow boys et aux indiens à lézan
dire sans hésitation je pense qu'on peut
alors aller leur prêter main forte ce
week end
merci beaucoup en tout cas mélanie pour
ce voyage en plein western
on passe maintenant notre agenda avec
deux concours qui vous attendent
[Musique]
à vos crayons pour le concours
d'affichés organisé à saint cyr l'école
dans le style manga votre mission si
vous l'acceptez dessinée sur le thème
des sept péchés capitaux
un concours ouvert à tous sans limite
d'âge vous avez jusqu'au 23 novembre
pour déposer votre oeuvre à la
bibliothèque albert camus et noël qui
arrive dans moins de deux mois bientôt
on verra fleurir les décorations dans
les villes à maurepas vous pouvez vous
inscrire pour le premier concours de
décorations de noël organisé par la
commune inscriptions jusqu'au 25
novembre résultats en janvier 2018 le
7-8 loisirs est maintenant terminé merci
de nous avoir suivis et n'oubliez pas
que ce vendredi 3 novembre c'est la
journée mondiale de la gentillesse
et comme disait le philosophe blaise
pascal les mots gentils ne coûte pas
cher pourtant ils accomplissent beaucoup
de choses je vous souhaite un excellent
week end et je vous retrouve la semaine
prochaine
[Musique]